Il ne restait plus
[Musique]
monter sur les hauts plateaux leur donner voir
à l'enfant de cet accueil la vérité
C'est beau et c'est ce que nous
assez fort
[Musique]
comme je l'ai dit le père noël donne des cadeaux
Noël aujourd'hui, ils m'ont donné un
cadeau agréable pour moi de vous saluer par le
fenêtres au-dessus de ces bâtiments
pour moi, il a été agréable que les enfants
te dire je t'aime tellement Père Noël que
Ce sont des rivières qui ont un peu de souffle
belle est le meilleur cadeau pour moi comme ça
Je pense que c'était l'inverse, je ne suis pas venu
donner des cadeaux je suis venu recevoir un agréable
cadeau de la vie aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et ma famille aussi immensément
reconnaissants parce qu'ils font un travail
exceptionnels se consacrent à prendre soin de nous
ils nous surveillent et plus à
apporte-nous cette joie au milieu de tant de choses
la tristesse est très précieuse non
[Musique]